the characteristic that this universe
the entropy seems to be always
increasing what does that show to you
about the evolution of
well okay so so for the University
entropy is yes okay and that's very
confused in history of thermodynamics
because entropy was first introduced by
a guy called Rudolph clausius and he did
it in terms of heat and temperature okay
subsequently it was reformulated by a
guy called Ludwig boltzmann
um and uh he formulated it in a much
more kind of combinatorial type way but
he always claimed that it was equivalent
to clausius's thing and then in one
particular simple example it is but that
connection between these two
formulations of entropy they've never
been connected I mean it's that there's
really so okay so the more general
definition of entropy due to boltzmann
is is the following thing so you say I
have a system and has many possible
configurations molecules can be in many
different Arrangements Etc et cetera Etc
if we know something about the system
for example we know it's in a box it has
a certain pressure as a certain
temperature we know these overall facts
about it then we say how many
microscopic configurations of the system
are possible given those overall
constraints
um and the entropy is the logarithm of
that number that's the definition and
that's the kind of the general
definition of entropy that turns out to
be useful now in Boltzmann's time he
thought these molecules could be placed
anywhere you want he didn't think but he
said oh actually we can make it a lot
simpler by having the molecules be
discrete well actually he didn't know
molecules existed right in those in his
time 1860s and so on uh the idea that
Mata might be made of discrete stuff had
been floated ever since ancient Greek
times but it had been a long time debate
about you know is math or discrete is it
continuous at the moment at that time
people mostly thought that Mata was
continuous
and um it was all confused with this
question about what heat is and people
thought heat was this fluid and um it
was it was a big big model and um the uh
and this boltzmann said let's assume
there are discrete molecules let's even
assume they have discrete energy levels
let's say everything is discrete then we
can do sort of combinatorial mathematics
and work out how many configurations of
these things they would be in the box
and we can say we can compute the
centropy quantity
um but he said but of course it's just a
fiction that these things are discrete
so he said this is an interesting piece
of History by the way that that you know
that was at that time people didn't know
molecules existed there were other hints
from from looking at uh kind of
chemistry that there might be discrete
atoms and so on just from the the
combinatorics of you know two hydrogens
and one oxygen make what you know two
two amounts of hydrogen plus one amount
of oxygen together make water things
like this but it wasn't known that
discrete molecules existed and in fact
the um uh people
you know it wasn't until the beginning
of the the 20th century that Brownian
motion was the final giveaway Brown in
motion is you know you look under a
microscope of these little pieces from
pollen grains you see they're being
discreetly kicked and those kicks are
water molecules hitting them and they're
discreet
um and uh in fact it was um it was
really quite interesting history I mean
boltzmann had worked out how things
could be discreet and have basically
invented something like quantum theory
in in the 1860s and uh but he just
thought it wasn't really the way it
worked and then just a piece of physics
history because I think it's kind of
interesting in in 1900 this guy called
Max Planck who'd been a long time
thermodynamics person who was trying to
everybody was trying to prove the second
order of thermodynamics including Max
Planck and Max Planck believed that
radiation like electromagnetic radiation
somehow the interaction of that with
Mata was going to prove the second law
of thermodynamics but he had these
experiments that people had done on
black body radiation and there were
these curves and you couldn't fit the
curve based on his idea for how
radiation interacted with Mata those
curves you couldn't figure out how to
fit those curves except he noticed that
if he just did what boltzmann had done
and assumed that electromagnetic
radiation was discrete he could fit the
curves he said but you know this is just
a you know it just happens to work this
way then Einstein came along and said
well by the way you know uh the
electromagnetic field might actually be
discrete it might be made of photons and
then that explains how this all works
and that was you know in 1905 that was
that was how
um kind of that was how Quant that piece
of quantum mechanics got started kind of
interesting interesting piece of History
I didn't know until I was researching
this recently in 1904 and 1903 Einstein
wrote three different papers and uh so
you know just sort of a well-known
physics history in 1905 Einstein wrote
these three papers one introduced
relativity Theory one explained Brownian
motion and one introduced basically
photons so kind of you know kind of a a
big deal year for physics and for
Einstein but in the years before that
he'd written several papers and what
were they about they were about the
second row of thermodynamics and they
were an attempt to prove the second
order of thermodynamics and their
nonsense
and so I I had no idea that he'd done
this interesting oh neither and in fact
what he did those three papers in 1905
well not so much the relativity paper
the one on Brownian motion the one on
photons both of these were about the
story of sort of making the world
discreet
um and then he got those like that idea
from boltzmann yeah um but boltzmann
didn't think you know boltzmann kind of
died believing you know he said but he
has a quote actually you know uh you
know in the end things are going to turn
out to be discreet and I'm going to
write down what I have to say about this
because uh uh you know eventually the
stuff will be rediscovered and I want to
leave you know what I can about how
things are going to be discreet but you
know
um I think he has some quotes about how
you know one person can't stand against
the tide of history in um uh in saying
that you know matter is discrete so so
he stopped by his guns it doesn't matter
is discreet yes he did and and the you
know what's interesting about this is uh
at the time everybody including Einstein
kind of assumed that space was probably
going to end up being discreet too but
that didn't work out technically because
it wasn't consistent with relativity
Theory it didn't seem to be and so then
in the history of physics even though
people had determined that Mata was
discrete electromagnetic magnetic field
was discrete space was a holdout of not
being discreet and in fact Einstein 1916
has this nice letter he wrote where he
says in the end it will turn out space
is discrete but we don't have the
mathematical tools necessary to figure
out how that works yet
and so you know I think it's kind of
cool that 100 years later we do yes for
you you're pretty pretty sure that at
every layer of reality it's discrete
right and that space is discreet and
that uh the I mean and in fact one of
the things I realized recently is this
kind of theory of heat that um uh
that the um you know that heat is really
this continuous fluid
um it's it's kind of like uh the the you
know the caloric theory of heat which
turns out to be completely wrong because
actually heat is the motion of a
discrete molecules unless you know there
are discrete molecules it's hard to
understand what heat could possibly be
well you know I think space is is
discrete and the question is kind of
what's the analog of the mistake that
was made with caloric
in the case of space and so I'm my my
current guess is that dark matter is as
I've my little sort of aphorism of the
of the last few months has been you know
dark matter is the caloric of our time
that is it will turn out the dark matter
is a feature of space and it is not a
bunch of particles you know at the time
when when people were talking about heat
they knew about fluids and they said
well heat must just be another kind of
fluid because that's what they knew
about yes but now people know about
particles and so they say well what's
dark matter it's not it's not it just
must be particles so what could dark
matter be as a feature of space Oh I
don't know yet all right um I mean I
think the the thing I'm really one of
the things I'm hoping to be able to do
is to find the analog of brown in Motion
in space so in other words Brown in
motion was was seeing down to the level
of an effect from Individual molecules
and so in the case of space you know
most of the things the things we see
about space so far just everything seems
continuous Brownian motion have been
discovered in the 1830s and it was only
identified what it was what it was the
the results of bias uh smallchowski and
Einstein at the beginning of the 20th
century and you know Dark Matter was was
discovered that phenomenon was
discovered 100 years ago
um you know the rotation curves of
galaxies don't follow the Luminous
matter that was discovered 100 years ago
and I think you know that I I wouldn't
be surprised if there isn't an effect
that we already know about that is kind
of the analog of brown in motion that
reveals the discreetness of space and in
fact we're beginning to have some
guesses we have some some evidence that
black hole mergers work differently when
there's discrete space and there may be
things that you can see in gravitational
wave signatures and things associated
with the discreetness of space but this
is kind of uh for me it's kind of it's
kind of interesting to see this sort of
recapitulation of the history of physics
where people you know vehemently say you
know matter is continuous
electromagnetic field is continuous and
turns out it isn't true and then they
say space is continuous But but so you
know entropy is the number of states of
the system consistent with some
constraint yes and the the thing is that
if you have if you know in great detail
the position of every molecule in the
gas
the entropy is is always zero because
there's only one possible State the the
configuration of molecules and the gas
the molecules bounce around they have a
certain rule for bouncing around there's
just one state of the gas evolves to one
state of the gas and so on but it's only
if you don't know in detail where all
the molecules are that you can say well
the entropy increases because the things
we do know about the molecules there are
more possible microscopic states of the
system consistent with what we do know
about where the molecules are and so the
question of whether
um so people this sort of paradox in a
sense of oh if we knew where all the
molecules were the entropy wouldn't
increase there was this idea introduced
by by Gibbs in the early 20th century
well actually the very beginning of the
20th century as a physics Professor an
American physics Professor was sort of
the first distinguished American physics
Professor um at Yale
um and he he entered reduce this idea of
course graining this idea that well you
know these molecules have a detail where
they're bouncing around but we can only
observe a coarse grained version of that
but the confusion has been nobody knew
what a valid course screening would be
so nobody knew that whether you could
have the score screening that very
carefully was sculpted in just such a
way that it would notice that the
particular configurations that you could
get from the simple initial condition
you know they fit into this coarse
graining and the course graining very
carefully observes that why can't you do
that kind of very detailed precise
course screening the answer is because
if you are a computationally bounded
Observer and the underlying Dynamics is
computationally irreducible that's
that's what defines possible core
screenings is what a computationally
bounded Observer can do and it's the
it's the fact that a computationally
bounded Observer is is forced to look
only at this kind of coarse grained
version of what the system is doing
that's why and and because the what's
what's going on underneath is it's kind
of filling out this this the the
different possible you're ending up with
something where
the sort of underlying computational
irreducibility is uh
your if if all you can see is what the
coarse grained result is with copy with
a sort of computationally bounded
observation then inevitably there are
many possible underlying configurations
that are consistent with that just to
clarify basically any Observer that
exists inside the universe
is going to be computationally bounded
no any Observer like us I don't know I
can't say like us what do you mean what
do you mean like us well
humans with finite Minds you're
including the tools of science yeah yeah
I mean and and as we you know we have
more precise and by the way there are
little sort of microscopic violations of
the second order of thermodynamics that
you can start to have when you have more
precise measurements of where precisely
molecules are but for uh for a large
scale when you have enough molecules we
don't have you know we're not tracing
all those molecules and we just don't
have the computational resources to do
that and it wouldn't be uh you know I
think the the to imagine what an
observer who is not computationally
bounded would be like
it's an interesting thing because okay
so what does computational boundedness
mean among other things it means we
conclude that definite things happen we
go we take all this complexity of the
world and we make a decision we're going
to turn left or turn right and that is
kind of reducing all this kind of uh
detail into we're observing it we're
we're sort of crushing it down to this
this one thing yeah and and that if we
didn't do that
uh we wouldn't we wouldn't have all this
sort of symbolic structure that we build
up that lets us think things through
with our finite Minds we'd be instead
you know we'd be just we'd be sort of
one with the universe yeah so content
to not simplify yes if we didn't
simplify then we wouldn't be like us we
would be like the universe like the the
intrinsic universe but not having
experiences like the experiences we have
where we for example conclude that
definite things happen we you know we we
sort of have this this uh notion of
being able to make make sort of
narrative statements